hi everyone my name is beryl
and i work in last mile delivery and i'm
joined by my colleagues today
josie principal engineer in robotics ai
aaron principal research scientist also
in robotics ai
and john senior principal engineer in
amazon fulfillment technology
so we're very much excited you're
joining us today and we're eager to
share
how our teams use science and
engineering to deliver for our customers
we're going to discuss the ways our
teams work to develop new solutions
keep up with consumer demand and
maintain a focus on sustainability
and even more but first let's begin with
intros
and i'd love to just hear about all of
your careers
and can you each briefly describe your
background
and what you're working on before and
before you join amazon
and what you're working on now and josie
let's start with you
sure i'm a principal engineer in
robotics ai
i lead a team to develop computer vision
for robots in our fulfillment centers
before amazon i have experience in both
startups and big companies
and i was also a professor of electrical
engineering at the university of
washington
in my free time i'm really passionate
about equity and stem
education and i've taught eighth grade
computer science to students at
rainier scholars for the last six years
yeah i'll go next i'm erin i'm a
research scientist
in robotics and ai org and i focus
on autonomous manipulation so i
specialize in
gripper design and robotic grasp
strategies
and i currently lead some prototyping
efforts uh so i spend a lot of time in
the lab running experiments
um and i'm trying to mature you know new
robotic capabilities to support our
order fulfillment network
um before amazon i was at nasa's jet
propulsion lab for 10 years
and there i founded and led the robotic
rapid prototyping lab and was a group
supervisor
for the extreme environment robotics
group
so good fun john yeah thanks
um so hello i'm john i'm a senior
principal engineer
in the fulfillment technology group and
um
unlike these other two most of my
professional career has been here at
amazon
i joined over 20 years ago now
back when amazon was still just a
scrappy internet startup a bookstore
on the world wide web and um
anyway fast forward to today currently
i i'm leading a lot of the work that
will help
in my mind at least shift amazon to a
more scalable
inventory and resource management and
process execution model
a lot of the models that we use to run
our operations and our fulfillment
centers and the rest of the network
this is also that amazon operations can
continue scaling
out our customer fulfillment for at
least another decade or so
all while leveraging a lot of the new
innovations that are happening
in automation data science algorithms
and as well as just
improving our human experience
well thanks all a pretty set of pretty
varied set of backgrounds and areas of
expertise
um so before before we get started i'm
going to quickly share a little bit
about
myself as well uh i've been with amazon
uh over 15 years and i actually joined
as an intern as a software development
engineer intern
and worked on a number of v1 products in
in devices
such as the first kindle before moving
to last mile delivery
several years ago so today my teams are
working on a few areas
including amazon flex pickup points and
lockers
mapping and routing uh and so on
uh okay so john you mentioned that
you're currently leading
work so that amazon operations can
continue to scale
customer fulfillment for another decade
or two how do you innovate to meet our
customers needs
um yeah so over the past few years a lot
of our focus
has shifted from building kind of
discrete standalone processes like
picking and packing stuff
to to building systems that manage
connected process flow
capable of optimizing and orchestrating
work in in large batches across
a very large building of connected
standard work processes
when we move to process control at that
level rather than
like discrete standalone processes we
can really help our people work more
efficiently with new types of robotics
and then also make better promises of
what we can realistically get done for
our customers
and also our employees the this kind of
production efficiency
uh systematized like helps us keep up
with the growth of
of well the new promises that we want to
make for our customers
and and without simply like building
new buildings everywhere everywhere that
we our customers are
so it helps us to scale
a few years ago um
another example of innovation that i was
thinking of is
you know we moved into the delivery
space which
barrel leads today and we had this idea
that we could build our own delivery
applications
and and if we did this we might be able
to connect those apps directly to our
customers
to enable them to own more of their own
delivery experience
and although now this idea seems very
simple
[Music]
like this allowed us to start having our
delivery providers
take pictures of packages as they left
them at our customer's doorstep
not only did this help amazon ensure
that the package ended up at the right
place
it gives our customers more visibility
that their package was delivered to
their house correctly
um it it basically improved the trust
between
our customers and amazon and also the
delivery providers that we have working
for us
kind of related to that another
far-fetched idea at the time was that we
could let our customers
also connect these deliveries to
smart connected devices like their car
trunk or even their garage door
or their front door by leveraging
iot internet of things technology and
connectivity
you know it's now possible for me to
order an expensive camera
and not have to worry about sitting on
my front front porch at all
instead i can see when it's being
delivered in my garage
i know it'll be safe until i can go get
my hands on it and
take it and play with it myself
parcel delivery has been around for
decades and
it's fascinating to me that amazon is
now in a position where simple
innovation and invention
can radically change this experi these
experiences for our customers
and also their expectations going
forward about how they might want
items delivered to them in the future
yeah and
the garage and home uh delivery products
were
ones that solved a real customer problem
and they were they were great to work on
so increased cut increased consumer
demand forces us to think outside the
box and innovate
and we need to continually keep finding
ways to meet this demand by automating
and improving productivity of existing
processes
we've had multiple examples in the
grocery space as well
especially through the pandemic
so josie and erin what are some of the
ways that
robotics ai science and engineering has
helped improve the delivery experience
for amazon's customers
josie let's start with you sure
um i mean it's just amazing how much
technology is involved
in shipping orders to customers um i
think like the speed and accuracy with
which we fulfill orders
is due to decades of innovation
we developed a package picking robot
that sorts packages to the correct
outbound truck
and this allows the robots to get the
right package to the right truck
which helps us provide consistent
delivery for our customers
and fewer errors
we also developed a computer vision
solution that can identify
when there's an incorrect item in an
order and this
obviously reduces the number of mistakes
that reach a customer
there's also um several computer vision
solutions
we've created to keep our employees safe
one of them is distance assistant it
shows on a monitor
when two people are standing closer than
six feet apart
and we put this in high traffic areas of
the fulfillment center
so that people can see when they need to
create more space between them
and we open source this code and people
have used it all around the world which
is really cool to see
totally aaron what about you yeah i mean
i would add a few things
uh you know everyone uh has had that
experience of receiving
a small item in like a large box um not
only is that
frustrating but it's also of course
expensive to ship the box
so we're working to improve how we group
and pack
uh multiple item orders into fewer boxes
uh that take up less space
um and that's actually like an a it's an
np
hard computational problem so it's a big
challenge
another thing i'd mention is all the
ways that amazon is enabling
us to receive our orders um so we're
inventing these new delivery locations
like
like john mentioned your car the lockers
also our physical stores like whole
foods you can also
specify the day or time of your delivery
or you can choose this no rush option
which is a much greener
choice and you can often get like a
digital credit if you select that
i love the no rush screener delivery
option
um so how else are we are you using
signs to make
amazon delivery more sustainable aaron
yeah you know there's a number of
initiatives here to
eliminate single-use packaging so
we have recyclable packages that use
less material
but we also have package list delivery
so one of those efforts that's already
in production is called
ship in own container and that's growing
really fast
diapers are a classic uh example
at my house these days as well so the
item already comes in a sturdy box
why would you put that box inside
another box to ship
you know you can just ship the diapers
and and so that's very popular one of
the things i'm personally been working
on in my lab is
is defining thresholds for damage to
these new package types
um so i've designed some test equipment
and processes
that can standardize and evaluate our
recyclable paper
and recyclable plastic mailers
just to make sure that the order gets to
our customer
um while also driving down our carbon
footprint
and there's there's kind of another
thing so just as shipping a small item
in a big box is wasteful
sending a large truck onto the highway
with only a small load in it
is similarly wasteful and similarly bad
for business
so we're using machine learning methods
to better plan the trucks
so that they can transport more per trip
and this is an area where amazon's scale
really offers like great opportunity
because the optimizations that were that
are available to us at this larger
scale are going to be way more impactful
than they are
for a smaller network of vehicles where
the constraints might be
a little bit greater i love how we're
thinking about both the
package level and the bigger truck truck
level
uh john can we get an engineering
perspective from you as well
yeah sure um so a general theme that i'm
actually very excited about is uh
leveraging where we are today
to build data and systems that can track
inventory
across our entire supply chain uh all
the way from the point where we order it
from our suppliers the manufacturers
uh down to how we process that flow
of inventory all the way to our
customer's doorstep
with this level of end-to-end visibility
we can build
optimization and controls into our
planning scheduling
and execution systems that minimize the
amount of stuff
that flows in and also reduce the wasted
movement and operations and activities
and just all the work that goes into
getting it all the way through
and and to our customers
we're now in a position where we can
also use sensors to accurately image and
physically measure all of these products
all the physical material products
that we're fulfilling to our customers
uh
as we um build this kind of factual data
set about all of our products then we
can better plan for how to pack them
into boxes as aaron described
put the right thing in the right box or
even no box at all when we
when we see an opportunity there
and then also even just moving into
shipping containers or trucks
that can more efficiently move again
trucks planes
everything along our delivery routes as
efficiently and as green as possible
so with better item data quality
eventually we should be able to build
processes
that can significantly reduce packaging
material entirely
without worrying about damaging the
products and all the stuff that
historically
have prevented us from you know just
handing products directly to customers
this will reduce a lot of the material
waste that we see today
as well as use less energy to move stuff
again through the entire supply chain
to me that's an awesome place for us to
be
agreed thanks john so uh building the
data sets and systems to track
inventory across amazon's entire supply
chain can become complex pretty quickly
and so how do we account for the
uncertainty
and complexity inherent in a large
system josie let's start
with you yeah you
have to solve problems in a completely
different way for it to scale
to the volume and variety of items we
sell at amazon
and i personally find that challenge
super fun
um we dive in deep to understand how our
fulfillment centers work
often working alongside the associates
to get that understanding
um like john said we collect a lot of
data from everywhere along the
fulfillment chain
and we really dive deep into
understanding patterns and trends and
anomalies
we create huge simulations that test the
ideas
at the building level or the
multi-building scale
we also prototype our ideas and test
them out in real fulfillment centers
with real orders
to understand where maybe we misjudged
reality
we also think about risk and what
experiments we can perform to reduce
that risk early on
um and we just design inherently
flexible and adaptable systems that
can learn and improve over time
yeah i'll jump on that um so big systems
large systems at the scale are certainly
you know there's a lot of uncertainty
and complexity uh
my my answer after all the time i've
been here is just embrace it
right while it's true that these large
distributed systems get kind of hard to
reason about
in our vision of perfection and even if
the basic requirements of the system
are change continuously
but it but it's not just because the
system is big the
uh this uncertainty is also coming from
frankly the evolving nature of our
business
and and our learnings about it and the
fact that we can offer new features over
time the more that we learn
and the more that we build so we can
iterate and
continue as we go this shifts our
thinking towards how to build
technology more organically and
iteratively
which frankly as an engineer is much
more satisfying i've spent over 20 years
again
like being surprised at
uh like what happens next with the
systems that i've built
i always think like oh i solved the
problem we got something out it's
excellent but then
um you know the next year is very
again very surprising and over time i
have begun to look forward to how much
that we can learn and discover
as we go um but from a systems design
perspective this does mean
design for scalability designed for
availability
at the component level at the system
resiliency and recovery level
and and also in the data models and the
apis
like they have to be extensible so that
we can involve them
and and that's just a crucial design
requirement in all of these systems
we're building sometimes
this extensibility is even more
important than
than getting the initial business
requirements correct like
it's okay to start with anything build
momentum and
after we've gotten started then we have
a path to evolve
the system into something that is big
comprehensive
and ultimately impactful to the business
well after 15 years here i'm also
surprised
here over here this thing's the same
over here
um okay so at the scale amazon is
growing
innovation continues to evolve too uh so
i'm curious
aaron how do you approach risk versus
reward
when it comes to innovation improving
the delivery experience for customers
yeah good question um so we have we have
a saying at amazon that it's it's day
one
so even as we grow and diversify we want
to continue to take risks
and continue to invent on behalf of our
customers
but to manage that risk we're often
rolling out these new initiatives
as prototypes that are limited in scope
and if it's working we scale it up to
the entire network
uh quickly and so we've become really
good at doing that scaling
um the good ideas of course come from
everywhere
and anywhere in our org uh
you know we have a very inclusive
planning process where
employees of any level um can contribute
concepts
even if they're for another team's
products or services
and if that idea gets a positive
reception we might write
a prep doc and so for these we try and
imagine
what would the press release say on the
day we launched this
new product and then we think of this
desired state and work backwards from it
and that really enhances and
distinguishes the great ideas it gets
you to think about the risks
and the benefits um you know you have so
many examples
in amazon's history of true innovation
uh even though we're a very large
company now
and i think it's due to some of these
processes so you know from prime
to kindle to aws and alexa
um you know you have current efforts
like kuiper and prime
air and the climate pledge
we don't just have good intentions here
we have mechanisms in place
that promote that risk-taking and
nurture these kinds of big
disruptive innovations and that's
something i love
you know about working here and i think
really sets
amazon apart and
what you said around inventing on behalf
of the customer is really important
we take a customer first view and we
work back from there
for example we know for certain that
customers want faster shipping speeds
and they want specific delivery related
problems to be solved so
once we identify those areas we move
ahead as you described
uh so aaron what's next for robotics ai
uh well we're kind of just at the
beginning for
machine learning and artificial
intelligence
i think there's there's a bunch of
places where we can improve the
experience of our customer
as well as the safety and satisfaction
of our employees
we see right now a lot of one-off use
cases of these technologies where we
write
a lot of specific and tailored code
for a narrow application and i see a
future state where these algorithms
become
you know more readily available and more
accessible
like through aws for example uh
at that point i think it it becomes just
another tool
in our toolbox and you'll see adoption
and innovation and comfort with those
systems
uh tick you know upwards pretty sharply
uh you know as a customer of amazon
personally
i i'm also like super excited about the
electric
uh delivery vans so looking forward to
seeing those
those on the road yeah i
i love aaron's points um it's really
we always think of it as just the
beginning here at amazon
um we're just always constantly trying
to find ways to get orders to customers
faster with lower cost and higher
quality
while keeping our employees safe it's
just what we do every day
um amazon's like john said constantly
changing and growing
and so uh we have to build
with adaptability in mind and develop
technologies that are flexible
and can extend like computer vision
solutions
that can learn to recognize the new
products that show up at amazon every
day
well that wraps up our session and i
want to give a huge thank you to josie
aaron and john
for joining me today and a big thanks to
everyone who tuned in
i hope you all found this helpful and
that you learned a bit more about the
innovation behind
amazon's delivery teams and check out
the amazon principal engineering
community page to stay up to date with
what the principal engineering community
is up to
and the amazon science blog to learn
about the latest research from
our science community thanks everyone
thanks pearl
[Music]
you